California is the country's largest
agricultural producer it's also running
out of water and that could have a big
impact on food prices this chart shows
how drought conditions have worsened
over the last four years more than forty
percent of the state is now in
exceptional drought and that could be a
problem for the whole country but eighty
percent of California's water is used
for agriculture it's a nearly 50 billion
dollar industry that produces dairy beef
eggs fruits nuts and vegetables more
than ninety percent of the country
strawberries figs grapes lemons
nectarines olives and plums are all
grown in California and it produces
about ninety percent of the country's
tree nuts most of these crops are grown
in the Central Valley a desert region
where the soil is great for growing but
requires heavy irrigation consider this
it takes about a gallon of water to
produce a single almond California
agriculture relies on snowpack in the
Sierra Nevada mountains but the snow is
at the lowest level in recorded history
the most recent measurement shows
snowpack ninety-five percent lower than
what's normal for this time of year the
state's reservoirs are also dangerously
low these images from NASA show the
Shasta Lake Reservoir California's
largest water levels have decreased
fifty percent since 2011 and with less
water consumers across the country could
pay more fruit and vegetable prices are
expected to rise about three percent
this year partially because of the
ongoing drought if conditions don't
improve soon this may only be the
beginning
Oh